it's now 6 33 and despite less travel
for all of us during the pandemic
traffic fatalities they have gone up
eight percent this year and the latest
report this morning from the state
shows at least 252 people have died on
our roadways
in 2020. hector mejia is live for us in
the southwest valley
with more on these tragic numbers hector
good morning to you
[Music]
good morning alex and here's another
heartbreaking number last year four
people died in car crashes on the day of
thanksgiving and according to the state
that's more
than the previous five years combined
one of those deaths happened at this
intersection right behind us
russell and durango when a driver ran a
red light t-boned another car
killing a woman inside it's still hard
to wrap my head around what happened
you notice one second she was gone
in this thanksgiving we're going to be
spending it at the cemetery
with the kids
i never thought in my wildest dreams
that that is
what where i would spend the holidays
with my daughter she was my only
daughter
this is the picture that is now on
monique prado's gravestone
the 30 year the 32 year old single
mother of three was out on the morning
of thanksgiving just
getting starbucks coffee with her 12
year old daughter when their car was hit
the victim's mother norma kennedy says
she does not like to focus on how her
daughter died
but she says if sharing her story means
saving at least one life
it's worth opening up for me my daughter
is never
coming back because of a decision that
somebody else made
to dry fall impaired my daughter has
three children
who no longer have a mother the two
youngest ones
are orphans they don't have a father or
a mother
i don't wish to just paint on anyone
nathaniel postel is the driver and his
blood alcohol level was reportedly
twice the legal limit last night i was
on the phone with the deputy district
attorney handling this case
he told me possible pleaded guilty to
dui resulting in death just
earlier this week the two other felony
charges were dropped in that plea
agreement
and postel is currently out on house
arrest and faces
anywhere between two and 20 years in
prison
his sentencing is set for march of next
year and the victim's family told me
they just want justice
the plea agreement means they will not
have to sit through a trial and
have to listen to the horrifying details
about the crash reporting live in the
southwest valley hector mejia
8 news now